[Musique]
c'est une histoire de sport de handicap
et d'amitié de dépassement de soi aussi
en piste avec les espoirs de
l'athlétisme handisport
alice 17 ans est en terminale déficients
visuels de naissance
une première sélection en équipe de
france sur 100 et 200 m
j'ai commencé la pierre pour pour me
vider la tête pour faire un loisir et
c'est ce qui m'a donné envie je prends
c'est de devoir que j'ai remporté des
médailles de voir que que j'aime la
compétition je suis très compétitrices
je me suis dit pourquoi pas yasser 15
ans en seconde double amputé fémoral de
naissance spécialiste du 100 et 200
mètres lui court en fauteuil
blackwater c'est son surnom je me sens
en symbiose avec lui bah c'est un peu
mon partenaire en fait il y toujours là
c'est grâce à du combat aiello même
peut-être 2024 peut-être c'est un parti
qu'on espère atteindre tout le monde va
travailler pour ça
tiphaine 16 ans amputé tibial après un
cancer elle est en première
sa spécialité le 100 200 m et le saut en
longueur
j'espère aller le plus loin possible en
deux et les moyens que je pense qu'on a
tous les moyens pour pour faire des
belles choses cette année juste régler
les petits problèmes médicaux prendre le
temps je pense que ça va venir sur un an
c'est lundi la semaine commence venue du
maine et loire après deux heures de
route typhaine et sa maman arrive à
l'internât du lycée choiseul à tour un
lycée avec des horaires aménagés pour
les jeunes athlètes du pôle espoir
handisport après un cancer du pied à
l'âge de 11 ans difficile à accepter
pour la famille
le sport a changé leur vie faut s'ouvrir
aux autres
mais il ya quand même le regard qui est
dérangeant des critiques des sons un peu
pénible mais bon une fois que on est
passé au dessus de tout ça on fait
abstraction de toute façon qui se donne
un objectif comme elle l'a fait et puis
déjà on bouge tout le temps on rencontre
plein de monde et vend des mois enfermé
sur saône elle du coup donc sociale ans
et joue beaucoup
puis même mentalement enfin rencontrer
du monde et de se re lire physiquement
bas c'est beaucoup mieux que doivent
être fermées ou allongés sur france 3 le
10 sport pour moi je n'en je me
considère comme valide donc su vahid
je veux pas rentrer dans ce monde de ne
pas handicaper je voulais pas accepter
en fait tu me l'as bon je trouve c'est
carrément mais en fait personne et comme
moi déjà dans les séjours c'est cool moi
je trouve ça original du coup autant
l'utiliser le cash
changement de décor entre les cours et
les entraînements du pôle les jeunes
athlètes gouttes au sport scolaire
on va faire des essais au gymnase
découverte du badminton avec des valides
la serbe et tiphaine très compétiteurs
ont déjà en vue un championnat de france
de sport partagé
c'est vraiment sur la fin que tu sais on
appelle ça relâché serré c'est sur la
fin le fait de serre et qui donnent de
la vitesse au volant d'accord si tu veut
souffler un petit peu
alors c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
c'est une expérience unique à la fois
pour mes section qui eux ils ont un
projet sportif corps comme leurs
camarades du pôle et avec les mêmes
ambitions et du coup ils se retrouvent
tout de suite engagé sur des projets
communs et s'est vraiment passé
fédérateur ces émulateurs et sacrément
une belle ambiance entre eux
m
mais j'avais un jour débrouille vraiment
bien franchement je m'y attendais pas et
c'est vraiment pas mal ok c'est cool on
partage quand même des moments avec des
passes ont connu qu'en france ça c'est
cool et j'aime bien c'est rapide c'est
le partage du coup et puis bah et à
l'ambition des jeunes il ya des gens qui
veulent y arriver donc ils veulent
passer notre cap c'est amusant si m6 ou
peas et mylène ya une compet du coup bah
voilà quoi c'est le moment qu'ils
attendent tous avec impatience les
entraînements six fois par semaine avec
le coach et les copains du pôle espoir
on a pas que j'ai mal au poignet à cause
du badminton
une équipe soudée et enthousiaste alice
après un mois de repos fait son retour à
l'entraînement suite à ces championnats
d'europe à berlin en août
une expérience inoubliable c'était une
audition assistée en tout cas j'étais
face à des sites très expérimenté donc
c'est vrai que ce soit je me sentais un
peu le bébé de l'avant j'ai beau avoir
une sélection internationale
je reste je suis vraiment pas la
meilleure et il ya encore beaucoup de
travail et il faut vraiment garder les
pieds sur terre je pense que c'est très
important
lionel lemaux orchestre du pôle espoir
coach confident c'est le lien de
confiance entre les familles et les
jeunes qu'il doit accompagner ou plus
haut niveau ont pas beaucoup de
résilience on parle beaucoup sur le fait
qu' ils soient plus forts mentalement
parce que par rapport au handicap
alors il ya une part de vérité moi c'est
pas mon avant que non le principal effet
travaillé sur le fait de pouvoir à
accéder sur le haut niveau
maintenant on sait qu' il ya des
parcours différents et et plus ou moins
complexes pour chacun et chacune d'entre
eux quand ils arrivent sur la piste
c'est vraiment leur force
j'ai oublié ses socios
retour au lycée il est 19h30
chaque soir typhaine et alice originaire
du blanc dans l'indre rejoignent
l'internât loin du cocon familial les
journées de ces jeunes sont intenses et
longue très longue
c'est assez longue après s'arrêteront à
prendre et on essaye de s'avancer la
journée pour pas avoir à les faire nos
devoirs
après ça fait de longues journées parce
que le matin on
né ici 7h30 et puis le soir des
critiques assez tard après
l'entraînement et puis ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'avec on a encore nos
devoirs à faire
douch à prendre sans notre soirée à
passer journées longues et nuits courtes
l'internât c'est aussi une histoire
d'amitié depuis l'an dernier elles sont
quatre à partager la chambre et d'alice
et tiphaine déjà fan
elles suivent leur parcours et profitent
de leurs conseils aux réflexions et aux
sommes pour le pour les pieds battu
force mais gentiment quand tu remontes
ses pieds action qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez un lycée tiphaine gaza jusqu
au bout de leur rêve qui a réussi un
[Musique]
retour au stade
yasser a d'abord essayé les lames de
course mais l'expérience n'a pas été
concluante
aujourd'hui ils bénéficient d'un suivi
l'espoir avec serge robert sélectionner
le jo d'atlanta
cet ancien athlète de haut niveau et
entraîneur de l'équipe de france en
fauteuil détecte ses potentiels
il ya certaines athlètes qui a la fibre
on va dire
c'est un beau potentiel samedi la tête
après c'est le préserver sauter la
course au fauteuil est un sport qui est
très long qui est très rigoureux qui
demande beaucoup
il faut dix ans pour être performant au
niveau interne donc il faut pas brûler
d'étapes il est tranquille à et surtout
accompagné que lui c'est pas le seul
il est jeune et a besoin de s'amuser se
faire plaisir avant tout aux personnes
qui viennent au travail sur de l'école
il initie donc faut pas que c'est donc
une charge qu'il faut jongler un petit
peu les deux c'est qu'on va essayer de
faire penser à sortir à jacques chirac
s'était risqué est passé de strictes
après tu verras que mes virages ne sont
pas elles sont pas réglés je sais pas
comment jacques padie c'est chaud
j'apprécie ya des gens qui prennent de
leur temps pour se placer pour nous pour
moi et pour paul mon coéquipier et bah
c'est tous les points qui sont
bénéfiques pour nous sont très bien
placés et puis on aller coûte
on prend ça avec beaucoup de rigueur et
on est attaché à synonyme des combles de
bons conseils comme ça
après l'entraînement corps une heure de
transport il est 20h yasser retrouve sa
famille à tour épuisé
je fatigue je suis tu alors ça samassa
massivement déplacés
voyez c'est du pratique nous pour ce
métal dans la maison plutôt d'utiliser
ses mains les convoitises des bassines
ces pratiques la vie de famille un
facteur clé dans la réussite du projet
des jeunes athlètes de l'amour du
soutien des parents admiratifs de la
motivation et des ambitions de leur fils
à 15 ans il ya séraphin faim de
victoires déjà sur une fois ceux
d'europe aussi à voir l'ensemble avec
l'équipe là et à la motivation celle
acquise on commence à fait les
compétitions elle a très bon mot je
vends mon fils changer les oreilles les
plannings bpa à boire du coca je dis à
papa maintenant c'est le niveau le
costume a dit si je vais ça je vais fait
la force mais les mendois fini les
kebabs faut pas oublier qu'en fait le
corps et leur état commente qu'ici baron
l'offre internet est en fait mal les
choses franchement quand je vois ça je
me dis wow et bedie le sport franchement
dans la vie ça aide beaucoup et et pour
son handicap
en tout cas personne n'avait pas parié
qu'ils pouvaient havas est forcément pas
le poids
et passer tout ça c'est à châteauroux
que nous retrouvons alice en famille des
parents propriétaires de cirque une
soeur voltigeuse et des valeurs
sportives partager son chapiteau depuis
l'enfance après un parcours douloureux
dans un club de gymnastique avec des
valides où elle n'avait pas sa place
il a fallu rebondir on a choisi le
d'athlétisme parce que c'est un peu le
hasard et c'est surtout les jeux de
londres qui m'a fait penser à ça mais
c'était moi c'était pas elle est donc je
voulais en même temps que ce soit son
choix et donc on on a réussi donc c'est
super ça ma famille cdi tout ça
de thérapie on va dire et d'accepter ce
syndicat bouquet voilà qu'il va lui
m'avoir ce qui est devenu une part de ma
personnalité et j'accepte totalement
aujourd'hui je sais que c'est un
exutoire je sais que ça peut ça permet
de repousser ses propres limites et et
de se vider la tête et d'aller de
l'avant donc donc je suis très heureuse
et je pense qu'il ya pas il n'y a pas
mieux pour elle pour s'épanouir et se
dépasser soi-même c'est bien mais quand
on court contre les autres iphone retour
à la piste pour une séance
d'entraînement très attendu par tiphaine
avec maria mille îles où furent une
fille en or
la championne paralympique multimédaillé
venus partager son ressenti du haut
niveau avec ses jeunes coéquipières
c'est sûr
voilà voilà chers vraiment pas de la
hauteur c'est j'anticipe le solde pour
vraiment aller au et de l'autre côté a
préparé pour moi la jeune génération
c'est vraiment un plaisir de partager
avec eux parce que finalement ce que
nous on nous a transmis en un mois on
est contents de leur dire et surtout moi
j'ai conscience que cette génération
elle n'a pas le temps que nous on avait
c'est à dire que nous on a eu plus de
temps pour devenir performant sauf que
vale niveau il est plus ce qu'il était
et qu'on va leur demander d'être ultra
performant 2024 donc si on peut leur
permettre de gagner un petit peu de
temps par rapport aux expertises qu'on a
acquis c'est vraiment un bonheur et
surtout d'addition ultra réceptif pour
le les protéger tous je pense que peut
m'apporter beaucoup de choses puisque
ben elle est vraiment vite et donc à
sacrément de quoi parle pas comme le
coach français mais il a les petites
techniques qu'elle n'a pas quoi penser
que des bonnes choses
le rêve de typhaine et lisse il ya serre
et tous les athlètes du pôle espoir
retrouvé mariam et les mots furent aux
jeux paralympiques de 2024 l'aventuré
belle elle ne fait que commencer
ça sera à paris dans le pays à face à
tous nos amis notre famille nos proches
donc le oui c'est un objectif très
important et on travaille pour ça
[Musique]